rainbow six extraction is a standalone
co-op game where up to three siege
operators sneak into locations infested
by an alien parasite
in this gameplay clip you'll see the
alaska map on the game's incursion mode
which includes three sub maps of
escalating difficulty
the gameplay shown focuses on the final
and most difficult sub map of the three
you can technically extract any time but
the longer you explore
the more xp and react tech you can get
to fight the aliens
the footage you see is from a game still
in development if you want to see more
rainbow six extraction
as well as be in the loop on all things
gaming from e3 and beyond
stick to game spot
auto tracker activated data acquired
we'll find out what's going on with
these nests
huh
me
triangulate the source at the first
station
uh
objectives
if you have a recon device it can help
you locate the objectives
commencing seismic triangulation
updating seismic triangulation
react scientists are disrupting the
propagation of the seismic waves
good teamwork
here
we're done in this sub zone you should
move to the next one
you've got a good thing going keep it up
in the next zone
let's get here
there's ammunition here
[Music]
airlock sequence initiated all personnel
to airlock immediately
reloading
turn on the catalyst emitter i'll get
readouts from your transceiver
head over there
if you have a recon device make use of
it
initiating data transfer hostiles
inbound
updates
incoming
now
you
if you don't extract it'll just be you
and your stasis device
i can't tell if you brought your a game
or this is too easy for you
[Music]
you